I'll do one more game let's do the
quickest game I'll do a challenge I'm
gonna sack my queen and like in the
first three moves and then it will be
Queen Anse actually um oh what a bishop
maybe I won't stack my queen
maybe I'll just I'll keep moving the
Queen and keep taking stuff well if
sleep is healthy that is true also
thanks for subbing math a monster
extended their their tier one appreciate
that okay I'm gonna keep taking stuff
maybe the challenge will be I'll just
move my queen the rest of the game and
take as many things as possible
yeah I'm not allowed to move any other
pieces unless I have to
ooh good move ooh very good move let's
take a pond let's take a queen or I take
with the Queen the Knights
the Queen is so strong I remember like a
Scholastic chess when I was like eight
years old I play the game where my
opponent did this to me
just moved out the Queen and took
everything and then accidentally
stalemated me in the end so it was a
good ending for anything mean - Wow oh
no the bishop could move to f1 oh I feel
so broken I feel so broken I didn't see
Bishop f1
I only saw Queenie blue I was just gonna
say let's put that on YouTube shout out
to the future YouTube people I just have
to make another Queen do I care about my
stuff let's not care about it Queen will
be reborn
this is such a ridiculous game I moved a
pawn move the Queen for a bunch of moves
and now it's this pawn doing work don't
Mimi please don't make me wait this is
scary kind of Oh opponent played this
thinking it's meat it's not meat now I
can safely pre move okay if I remember
I'll probably put this on YouTube
the queen is reborn the maid is
delivered you two people smash the like
button and I'll see you in the future